[Music]
I think I'm gonna be sick
no I just stepped in a dead man's blood
and I think one of the Flies landed on
my mouth if you're going into the
apartments do not go into the lower one
on the right that's where the body's now
if you'll excuse me I need to go
contemplate a hot shower
[Music]
oh sorry sorry just booked me was all
even stellar baying safe these days
what's the world coming to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think of the unreliable
Parvati there's always something to fix
and it's neat working together I always
took atmo for granted now if I drill
through the hole we all suffocate
excited you know I I'm not sure I wanted
to know that being in space sets me on
edge enough you know about stellar
emissions actually I probably shouldn't
tell you about those I'm he not unless
you want to know how we're all likely to
get spacers long right okay we get back
to the ship I'm drinking this
conversation right out of my
recollection ooh you're the new face Wow
you must be up on all the latest
possible games so who do you follow wait
don't tell me you look like a
Hammersmith Thunder fan no glacial age
mammoths I've heard they got a new
hacker is that why everyone's making
such a fuss about you but what are you
doing on monarch huh maybe we're not so
isolated as I thought so what can I do
for you
[Music]
poor Isaac I was wondering why I hadn't
seen him in a few days I'd really like
to help Isaac was a sweet fellow even if
he did have terrible teeth right so the
thing with Isaac is he didn't know where
to stop
he'd get stuck on something and he just
couldn't let it go sometimes he'd drink
purpleberry punched by the leader other
times he'd keep betting on a losing team
started owing the wrong people money I
don't know for sure but I saw Elijah and
his buddies pushing Isaac around they're
hooligans from Fallbrook they sweep into
town drop supplies off behind the
warehouse and spend the rest of their
stay getting rowdy over toss ballgames
they usually loiter in the alley behind
the Yacht Club they're not allowed in
the bar anymore I bet you anything Isaac
ran into trouble with one of them mr.
Sanjar I'll be pleased to hear about it
when you're done I know he gets fed up
with the Fallbrook bullies but there's
not much he can do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who the [ __ ] are you this ain't hey what
are you doing here this is our secret
ally Berta already pissed by those
crates to market listen
that purple tooth tour had it coming not
that anyone has proof and not that it's
any of your business
I don't think so you're a loose end now
[Music]
could I get another well new business
turns up at last
Celia didn't I tell you our new
statistics based advertising model would
be a hit that you did sir how can yield
improvements of 26.7% not quicken the
pulse how can three 2% cost savings not
moisten the loins you've often posed
these very questions clear my schedule
this newcomer has a meeting with me
Celia will you make a note of that for
my self review very generous noted what
can I do for you that's terrible
what happened but that means we won't be
able to log their testimonies if there's
one thing I've been hoping to
re-establish in stellar Bay its proper
documentation for legal matters always a
shame when tempers get the better of
good sense still your intervention in
the matter is much appreciated please
consider this payment for your services
[Music]